hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jeremy and
Jeremy's back today that's right
we're gonna watch the trailer for the
purge anarchie the sequel to the purge
there's like the second or third trailer
can't remember
have you seen the purge I see the first
one the previews were dope yeah but the
movie was so predictable I was very
depressed and by the end of the movie
yeah cuz there was such an original plot
and then you get like me make it very
like so stereotypical yeah yeah pretty
cliché yeah I have you seen the trailer
Selene anyone any other one of them did
you like it
I was kind of excited cuz it's not just
one house ya know like just this go
crazy you know yeah purge it go rob a
bank go do some crazy [ __ ] exactly and
I'm hoping that's what this movie gives
us is like exploring the world at a time
yeah not so exploring the one place that
tries to keep it safe
that's I like the title anarchy yeah
anarchie and our key from Dark Knight
that's what's up right there yeah mm-hmm
forgot about this lipstick all right
let's do this
rated R for strong disturbing violence
and language I like that already
language traffic is building rapidly
downtown as citizens rush to get home
stay safe sweetie they say
you're not it's not gonna be safe to get
off it's not an all via war okay it's a
real news report yeah this is the
commencement of the annual purge all
crime including murder dangerous is this
won't bring him back
it won't make you feel any better don't
do this Riley yeah my it's better nice
dad exactly we don't say eyes
who's that I quit taking lives who can
just drive it is dark at all yeah poor
Blake man I just get in the car oh my
god
oh [ __ ]
why don't you just kill this already
this is a superb fresh office what the
hell is the last curve should be the
beating of started 200,000 purchase sit
up we'll see you shortly London grouse
Hunger Games yeah they're making the
fish then I've been had people who kind
of also been happening wise oh [ __ ] look
back there life Oh
the purge does I know Wow all the good
the purge just look good yeah but you're
killing it that's so good for the human
society [ __ ] man the purge that looks
uh I'm I'm appealed to it it looks
promising yeah I mean if it's like gory
and you know violent and crazy [ __ ] yeah
that's that's what I kind of like the
whole Hunger Games running man they like
what was the whole point of like selling
these people um I think they were
bidding on them yeah I'm like who would
win or who a dyers I don't know that's
yeah huh I understand go watch the movie
to find out yeah piqued my interest a
little bit it did
I just hope the previews weren't the
only good parts in the movie no I'll
check it out though like I mean I kind
of like the lead characters a little bit
of a badass yeah he is very real
the go study yeah perfectly shaved every
father the best boy yeah I'm sure it'd
be fun what else oh my god [ __ ] do
that day yes sir
we should just watch it together man
that'd be cool madam the mandate mandate
yes oh if this was like 60 years ago
mandate would have been what we did on
the purge cuz oh [ __ ] wasn't acceptable
back then that's what's a joke meant
mmm-hmm what would you do on the purge
hmm I'm from a big yeah lemme come on
Shu just rob a bank like there's you
can't not do anything so just get a few
grenades or some c4 blow up the place
grab it you just wear a mask the one who
you are all of a sudden you're rich as
[ __ ] but wouldn't you think the bank
they might have a lot of life it might
be hard to break into it's true that's
what you get a team of people that know
what they're doing oh I gotta build is i
tortured ain't nothing happens cuz we
sealed everything up just like the
recall just goes back in yeah
that's what I would do what would you do
what would I do um I would I would a I
would rob some of your money that you
run hey give me so easier like let me do
the hard work job I'll just take it
that's smart and then probably a lot of
a lot of illegal prostitution if you
could find them they might be hiding
they might be but you could always find
a hooker alright guys well thanks for
checking out us watching stuff why don't
you subscribe if you're new to the
channel and Jeremy he's ID he's into
like fitness and dancing and he's he's
one it was more than just all about
health and stuff but yeah check out his
channel what's your channel called again
Jeremy shot it's just my name Jeremy
shine Jeremy shot I can you be simple
heaven and OH
I got to do some shoutouts show don't
Marko Mondragon do please do a shout-out
because I watch you everyday and think
that you're awesome well Marco Polo you
you I think you've asked for a shout-out
before but I'm giving you one cuz that's
what was next
it gets confusing when Yuri requests but
they look like a rhyme yeah don't I
think I call myself
rhyming right rhyming right Oh private
fist me there you yeah Marco um I just
revealed my rap name for you that's what
you get that's how special your shadow
okay and he's a dragon and you're
annoying dry got a Mondragon what does
that dafuq is a Mont I don't know but
he's a dragon I don't know Mondragon
sounds a little bit maybe spits fire any
please Marco Polo ooh yep don't like
somebody play Marco Polo Verbeck oh yeah
I know but that pool game yes you're
making me uncomfortable Marcus Brian
Franco he said if you gave me a
shout-out please send me the vid I'll
see if I remember to do that for you
yeah I I see I film a lot I film several
and then I
edit them like kind of in whatever order
and so sometimes this little noggin
don't remember do [ __ ] like that for
people but if by the time this video is
up and I do remember to do it you will
get it if not hey come on man you
seriously you should be looking out for
the shoutout
you better do [ __ ] asking you say
you'll watch every year so he sees his
name I'm not gonna watch your video so
can you just send me the vid when I get
the shoutout
Gustav Helstrom Ryan I'll be your Butler
if you give me a shout-out look at all
the last film nation Mars that he's
serious he really wants you to be his
Butler Gustav that's a good name I be a
great Butler his name Gustav
yeah little towel here Gustav I can't
your biceps are [ __ ] insane the veins
are like popping out right now don't you
can see them on campus [ __ ] crazy
there you go let's just do a lot of that
that helps out actually does it just you
know you have like every vein to find
there's got really lucky tonight yeah
okay thank you stuff um yeah dude um if
you want to be my Butler that sounds
pretty awesome dude I could use a butler
I'm horrible like keeping care of my
place man like these girls come over all
the time and I'm just like flop yourself
on the couch I'll turn on the camera you
know I like to have a butler
are you um British are you black and
British I'm basically looking for
Geoffrey from Bell yes oh so yeah
black and British with a Russian person
yeah yeah and make your stuff you have a
good day and I'll send you my address
just message me okay if you're serious
about the whole Butler thing Butler's
work for you now you got hurt I think
you gotta hire them yeah you might want
to volunteer I want volunteer oh that's
called servants you want me yeah take
that back
you know that Roshan I'm not racist yeah
not at all racist I have many black
friends mm-hmm they're all subscribers
yes